this is a production of cornell
university
thanks for joining us john i'm going to
just take a couple of minutes and make
my way
uh through an update to set the stage
for our conversation
uh the fastest 30 minutes in turf we we
like to call it and
it's an hour and a half if you uh look
at all three webinars during the week so
uh always i'm i'm a good uh visitor of
twitter
uh love to see a tweet of somebody
helping out
on the golf course and and i gotta tell
you there has to be
some lag effect that these some of these
things that look cute now are gonna have
people are gonna
bump into things it's like yeah it's
actually pretty cool working on a golf
course
well i think i can get up and do this
and the next thing you know
you see wonderful videos uh like just
came out the other day
um i think it was a bunch of uh
turf professionals talking about really
enjoying the work and students being
involved so
a lot of good and of course families
being together on the course is
is always a positive thing uh carl was
out carl our resident professional
golfer who
decided to take up gainful employment
and made the mistake of
working with me all these years uh i was
out playing golf at one of our wonderful
state park golf courses carl
make sure you put a leak to all those
wonderful state park golf courses
and the steps we're taking to uh uh you
know address the needs of cart use right
and here is uh
the golf pro or member of the soaring
eagle staff big shout out to those guys
of course was in great shape carl tells
me uh and sanitizing the golf carts
right there's probably many ways to skin
this cat
uh um and so there's a video on facebook
that carl
can uh direct you to and listen this is
nobody knows how to do this i didn't
nobody went to school for how to
sanitize a stupid golf cart right
i mean it's like a lot of things in this
business it's it's common sense oriented
so
you know there's lots of ways to do it
but my advice
is to get a procedure in place there's
places to start
right uh the new jersey superintendents
i was poking around again in preparation
for this the other day i'm like yeah
how much more do we have and i'm like
yeah the jersey guys what they got from
easy go is still one of the best uh
things we have just about how to deal
with this now what's
interesting and you know you look into
this a little bit and all of a sudden
we're spraying sanitizer everywhere
i have a friend over at pesticide
management education here at cornell the
pmet program that administers
all the pesticide training for all the
categories
uh run by the dec this is a private
operation here
not a private operation it's a sort of
an enterprise operation at cornell's
many years lived on dec funding and now
has to
sort of determine how it's going to be
in the future but
recently uh with all the concern about
oh we got to spray these things i mean
you know
wha what's he spraying what is that
we're spraying something to kill
something and so the pmap is trying to
give
guidance on this and directing you to
this wonderful website
that the dec put up and updates
apparently was updated on the 8th
uh most recently i took this off just
the other day
uh of products you can use products that
are labeled
right if you're going to start doing
this and we're going to start exposing
people to these things right
we better make sure uh we're at least
using products now i'm sure somebody's
going to ask do you have to be
certified to do this and carl i don't
know the answer to that question but
it made me think about it certainly
something we should explore now we're
going to be spraying these things down
uh with disinfectant i mean there's no
reason to think it it's a problem i mean
i don't know you have to be certified to
use
disinfectants in your bathroom uh so i
don't know why you would have to be but
certainly worthy of exploration uh just
to note
returning to normalcy right i look at my
email this morning
and i get this from the mags the
mid-atlantic superintendents down there
uh in the chesapeake bay and they're
having this challenge
between the eastern shore and the
mid-atlantic every year
and it's a golf tournament and so here
is you know
all right what are these guys gonna do
all right here's how they're gonna do it
i thought the second one was very
interesting you can have foursomes
but you can only have two cards and only
one person can use a cart the other
person's got to walk the whole way
but both bags have to be in the cart all
right 15 ways to do
this to try to keep hey can one of yours
walk
you know can one of us walk right and so
uh and that sort of saves us a little
bit on the traffic thing i thought that
was pretty cool from those guys anyway
for those of you everywhere else but in
upstate new york this is what i woke up
to today
i walked out the door uh looked at the
sun shining on a barn across the street
and there it is snow on the ground
so i don't need to tell you how far
behind
we remain uh from what looked like was
going to be
you know guys putting pre-emergents and
summer patch materials down at the end
of march
early april to now essentially the
conversation with john today will be
about
that particular fact and addressing
those root born pathogens but you can
see from our weather data from our
forecast website
that we're just not changing very much
and the forecast
looks a little better looks a little
better we're in the double-digit
accumulation now
of base 50 growing degree days this is
not a place we've been
really since early april it's more than
six weeks since we've been able to
accumulate
more than just single digits in much of
new york state and
probably like john along the coast and
in stores
maybe a little bit more because of the
impact of the water bodies
now the conversation for today is really
about root pathogens i know you know
john was
one of the many scholars that came out
of the rutgers anthracnos initiative
for many years john did some wonderful
work there but of course the most
important thing is he
walked away with his lovely wife
michelle decosta another wonderful
professor at the university of
massachusetts
but while they were theirs uh john was
studying annual bluegrass and
anthracnose and
turjan presents this sort of growth
model for the way
annual bluegrass grows and and michelle
is studying bent grass i think it was
water stress as i recall
fairway water management back in the day
uh looking at bank grasses different
types of bent grasses but one of the
things we know
about bank grasses and bench grass root
growth right is that you're going to get
a lot more root growth early on then
you're going to get top growth on a lot
of these bent grasses if we're talking
roots for today
all right so let's since we're talking
roots let's talk about cell temperature
here is
uh where we were uh about six weeks ago
you could see it was looking okay we're
about to have our
our triggers hit uh for uh our summer
patch and
and take all patch sprays and and then
may 4th
uh you could see last week we were
uh really sniffing at it again and you
wake up today
and the two-inch soil temperature which
is a very uh reflective
of the air temperature simply will not
budge
beyond the mid 50s even in the urban
areas
okay so uh fairy ring and summer patch
take all patch
are the topics for today mostly summer
patch
and some take off no fairy ring uh today
john no worries but uh i took i take and
use this publication if you don't have
this
uh on your desk it's it's really the
most practical guide
available and as soon as the compendium
maybe gets done at some point
uh is the compendium done john
i think they if it's not done um
yeah they're just i think they're kind
of wrapping it up so um yeah i think
we're pretty close
yeah that's the nice companion to this
particular publication and
and so i found uh some of john's work
on the internet um where he was giving a
presentation about
this particular topic and his research
and there are always been some
particular things he's noticed that have
fascinated me in this case
you can see the very typical summer
patch you might see
on a intermediate rough next to a
fairway or a collar
next to a putting green john took this
wonderful picture this has got to be an
all-time this is a hall of fame picture
in my opinion
for a root disease where he's taken the
sample
you can see where he's taking the sample
from right at the edge of the patch
you know i don't want to i don't
interrupt you here frank but just a
second because there's something real
interesting this photo i think what's
great about this photo
oh this one yeah go
no no back up to the uh the mowing
height oh there you go
what what i think is really interesting
in this in this photograph
so you've got a creeping bentgrass um
putting green there obviously and then
you've got your
your first step cut kentucky bluegrass
at the exact same cultivar of kentucky
bluegrass at three inches and one and a
half inches
and what this what this photograph
really illustrates is the effect of
mowing height
on summer patch okay so i mean you've
got summer patch
in that one and a half inch cut i
guarantee you have i mean
obviously shows the species difference
but
in the three and a half excuse me in the
three and the one and a half inch
mowing heights the pathogen is there you
don't see the diseases prevalently in
that three and a half and that three
inch
mowing height because the height of cut
is greater presumably we have more
roots okay we have more root mass we
have more numbers of roots
and and i think it just illustrates very
much summer patch is a war of
attrition the more roots you have
the more roots you can tolerate losing
and still maintain acceptable turf
and so here is the image of the healthy
roots going through the elfification
hole
and along the patch here along the patch
where you took the sample
you can see that the roots have declined
so
obviously john if the roots were more
prolific
outside of the air frication holes
that would help this side
of the sample but it also demonstrates
at least
the potential value right that
verification and relieving compaction
uh can have so so listen this is what
the guys are saying
in that manual i'm assuming somewhat uh
dependent on your work
because they talk about it here uh and
there's
two particular issues going on one is
the manganese applications and the other
is using errification in two
forms to alleviate compaction one with a
solid tine and one with a hollow tine
right
and then the manganese sulfate
application and when you look at
uh what they recommend uh from
your work uh based on on your work
these are uh some of the speculations
now
now let's start with um let me get let
me get to the picture
here's the picture right so so john
you want to take her from here and talk
about this a little bit rather than me
yakking
yeah yeah so you know the interesting
thing
um this was this was research that we
had done
um looking at compaction uh and
different types of cultivation practices
both hollow time and solid time
and um you know one thing that we saw
you know kind of going back there
in this study where we didn't compact
the soil
we could not get the disease so it just
really reinforces
how important compaction is this disease
is definitely dependent on compacted
soils reduced again
again war of attrition the amount of
roots compacted soils having less roots
increases the likelihood or the severity
of this disease
okay so these photos all show compacted
plots all right but we have hollow and
we have solid time okay
um and uh what we did see was that in
some cases we had a little bit of an
issue
with the solid times okay um
what we what we can see in this top
three photographs at the top right this
is a panel showing
uh the the additional factor that we
were looking at which was main
uh this manganese okay so when we look
at the top three photographs we can see
that
none of these plots have manganese we
see that the solid tine which is in the
middle that's frank circled there
uh has you know six clear patches of
summer patch disease
all right if we look at the hollow tine
we see there's no
disease okay if we look at the no
or the no cultivation we can see faintly
a little bit of disease in there
okay but what we're seeing here is that
the solid tine actually increased
the amount of summer patch okay and
you know this was a little bit
surprising to me at first i mean
obviously we see holotyne reducing the
disease as we would expect because we're
leaving compaction
solid time actually increased it and
what we
what we also did in this study is we we
measured compaction
okay um but we also measured use the
penetrometer
okay and so what we did is we actually
excavated a
a soil plug three inches deep which is
the depth
of our tines okay and we removed
an intact core to a three inch depth and
then we put a penetrometer right on that
spot
and we were able to see that we had
developed a little bit of a hard pan
um from repeatedly solid timing to that
same depth
every year okay in a native soil in a
native soil
in a native soil thank you yeah um and
so
because we're you know solid timing to
that same level we weren't removing that
core
uh presumably we're creating a little
compaction layer or a pan layer right at
that
uh at that three inch depth all right so
listen let's go back
let's go back to because you've
explained the first three parts of this
the last part is the manganese uh and
i'm assuming it was manganese sulfate
of some sort that's correct um you know
the question in the manual and i'm
wondering about it
is have you done any more work to
show you need um these
uh subsequent applications is there a
level of manganese in the soil john
that that um that we need to have now
now remind everybody why manganese in
particular is important with these
diseases if you would
so i mean manganese is you know it's a
nutrient required by the plant
um you know at a base of basic level
it's usually utilized in the chlorophyll
molecule and it's important for
photosynthesis and greening of the
leaves but in addition to that
it also has roles in plant defense um
uh manganese is one of the components
that's involved in
in making phenolics which are these
compounds that
uh that plants will produce that can be
toxic to fungi
and so when the fungus infects the plant
these phenolic compounds these chemicals
that the plant make
to get in there and they kind of degrade
that mycelium as it's penetrating the
plant so
chemically manganese helps the plant
form these chemical defenses and it also
helps the plant form
lignin okay this is a structural defense
okay
so it makes those cell walls stronger
and more resilient to infection by the
pathogen as well so
so manganese is involved in both
physical and chemical
uh defense and this is true for take all
as well on ben
yes okay so how much do we have to do do
we have to apply it all the time
well so the questions that you brought
up with
uh with what is the rate what is the
interval um
you know these are these are these are
important questions that
um that we are looking to address i
actually um
we've got funding from the tri-state
research foundation um where we're
looking at
uh looking at this in more depth about
manganese availability and what is that
critical
amount of manganese to to reduce the
disease because and you know
the the old work that bruce did years
ago back
you know in the early 90s also showed
the value of uh
ammoniacal nitrogen ammonium sulfate
compared to calcium and potassium
nitrate
yeah where does that fit into this do i
need this
do i need is it the acidification as
much as the manganese does the
acidification
potentially release the manganese
yes um so what the
so manganese is um is a nutrient that's
ph dependent
okay so as the ph becomes lower
the amount of plant available manganese
increases
okay okay and so um so what we see
is you know that's why we generally well
there's a lot of reasons we generally
see
less summer patch when our ph's are
lower okay
6.8 seems to be like kind of a cardinal
value that a lot of us throw around
um that if you're above 6.8 a likelihood
of having you know
much more significant summer patch
problems is greater
but you know the severity of the disease
will decrease at lower phs
um but so as the at those lower ph's
manganese be is
is more plant available and you know
that could be a factor in why
you know we see less of the disease at
lower lower uh phs
ammonium sulfate reduces the ph right at
the root zone
like right around the root okay so it
doesn't reduce this bulk soil ph
very quickly but it can have a dramatic
effect
on the peak right at the root right
where the pathogen is trying to infect
the roots
and so um so that's you know presumably
why we do see
um a significant impact of of
reducing summer patch severity with
those applications of ammonium
any ammonium-based fertilizer okay so so
from a cultural perspective
this is an area where nutrient
management and ph
adjustment soil chemical properties can
play a role in managing a disease right
that's there's
good solid research in this area over a
long period of time
uh and of course alleviating compaction
and
maximizing your root mass and depth of
course is is going to be important
and then it's the the what we always do
which are the early season drenches
john um that are done when the you know
to go back to this
this this note here right this
persistent
temperature uh at a two inch depth uh
that they've published on summer patch
uh
in the manual here um we're not there
yet does this feel weird that we're not
there yet would you have put it down
already
if you put it down is it gone this is a
very confusing time i think
uh for this particular thing that's why
i wanted to have you on
yeah yeah no i mean um
you know every year is different that's
why you know that's why we certainly i
always encourage people
to actually measure their soil
temperatures to go by a calendar
is really challenging with these
these types of applications i mean we're
investing a lot
in these in these applications these are
expensive applications
high rates multiple applications lots of
water timing
so you know so it's really important to
go that extra mile
to measure those soil temperatures and
i'm not talking i mean you know frank
showed some great photos
some great graphics um showing you know
regional soil temperatures based on the
newa site and that's great um but you
got to do that
you got to do that on your own site for
yourself that's right
um you know you gotta you know where you
have summer patch problems it's a
historical disease it's gonna show up in
the same spots year after year
so you need to be getting a soil probe
out there and and measuring the
temperature
of those soils at a two inch depth i
suggest
afternoon two o'clock in the afternoon
is what i typically stick with
and you want to be consistent you'll see
a huge difference in that soil
temperature at two inches if you're
measuring in the morning versus the
afternoon okay
it's responsive to air temperature right
it's responsive to air temperature okay
so you know listen there's a lot of
things we can talk about regarding this
and of course one of the things that we
beat on is
when i talk to bruce about summer patch
and why it fails sometimes he says
basically two things
sometimes guys get lazy and don't put on
a high enough rate
right you you don't have it for a while
you think you can get by with a lower
rate
and consistently they don't put on
enough water
um that seems to me to be the story
right john
water you've got to be able to drench
these things into where the roots are
i mean that's you know to our to our
best knowledge right now i mean that's
that's what we're what what we would
expect i mean this is a root pathogen
fungicides do not move down in the plant
okay
we we we want to protect those roots and
the only way we can protect those roots
is by getting the fungicide to the root
and so you know maximizing our ability
to do that
whether that's you know a combination of
watering it in
i also think about i also think about
uniformity of wedding
profiles okay you know using wedding
agents and making you know
you've seen the photos with the fingered
water movement right
you know think about that's where your
fungicides going okay and so if you
don't get good uniform
wetting profile down through the soil
then your fungicides not going to
uniformly treat your roots either
so you know i think you really want to
be thinking about trying to
maximize getting that fungicide to the
roots
because it's challenging right we use
such high rates because
you know a lot of these fungicides we
use they have an extremely high affinity
for the organic matter in our soils
okay so a lot of the fungicide that
we're putting there doesn't get to the
root because it gets locked into the
organic matter
so again you want to try to create that
you know i like to think of
you know if you've got problems with it
you know maybe having a pre-treatment
with a wetting agent before you apply
the fungicide
you get a uniform wetting profile and
then having that material move down more
uniformly
uh and maybe you know help improve the
uptake
and and that is uh you know that's a
whole conversation what you just went
through
on the way soils wet how fungicides move
and i think to a certain extent i've
always described this application as a
drench
so that guys you know put on ridiculous
amounts of water
because you're right once that fungicide
gets there with the organic matter it's
going to bind
and it's going to make it more difficult
to sort of do its thing on
you know get into the plant and and
provide the protection what i think is
fascinating and less talked about
is this particular fact john i have to
say up until last week when i was
thinking more about preparing for the
conversation
i went through the guide and what is
this about where
fungicides applied as curatives
uh seem to be enhancing it or causing
damage
um fungicides apply
torque caused phytotax bluegrass and
several it says that when you spray
dachnal and chipko you're getting more
damage i i
enhance symptom development i have never
seen that i don't think they're talking
about the
they're not talking about uh applying
chlorothalonil or hyperdione as curative
applications for dog
for for summer patch because neither of
those fungicides are really going to
give you any control of summer patch
right right you're using these things
for probably dollar spot or something
else during the
mid to late summer right so yes it's not
for
summer patch but when you use it it
seems to enhance
uh summer patch yeah so i mean so this
is information that's
you know dr clark down at rutgers has
seen this in his field trials
where uh even like some of the pre-mixed
uh fungicides that are available on the
market where it's a dmi by itself
compared to a premix with dmi plus
chlorothalonil
they're seeing more summer patch um in
the
in those treatments that have the
chlorophylline on it
not that it's increasing it compared to
untreated or anything like that but
but they're not as effective uh when you
put chlorophyllin or epidione
and you know the real reason for that is
not we don't we can't say
exactly at this point but essentially
what we're seeing is maybe
maybe you know this you know we're all
there's all kinds of buzz about
microbiome
phytobiome and this kind of thing you
know is it a situation where we maybe
have some natural antagonism
uh to the to the summer patch pathogen
um
and and that the chlorothalonil or
hyperdione might be
you know suppressing those beneficial
organisms and maybe potentially
increasing the severe disease
we don't really know i'm speculating
yeah that's great i love that that's
what we're doing and nobody's listening
anyway john it's just us
all right carl yeah just me you and carl
and i think
uh you know that's the kind of thing we
need to get out there because
these are the things that still need to
be studied now let's listen we're
getting close to the witching hour call
but
i haven't talked about take all john and
i
you know i i you know now that more guys
are getting bent grass
um certainly you know you're not going
to find bank grass like you're going to
find
poa or some things on on heavy heavy
soils unless they're fairways of course
but again
bank grass this is a primary problem i
would assume of of fangrass
but the control that's recommended that
i don't see
for summer pets and i wonder if it's
just the nature of the way people have
researched it john
this is saying that actually for
outbreaks in the spring
they wanted you to treat last fall is
this a pretty standard
recommendation for take all applications
and does that mean
a spring application is really not worth
it
i mean i i would tend to agree with this
um you know and the reason
that the timings of these two different
uh fungicide applications are different
is because the activity the growth of
the pathogens are are very much
different
uh take all gematomyces tends to be um
active and growing actively and
infecting plants at cooler temperatures
okay it actually starts to it shuts down
during the warm summer months
okay but in the fall it begins to become
it reactivates okay so you can start to
get those infections
in the fall which is why we suggest
those fall applications
and the spring applications you know you
could almost
think about that as you know oh what if
i start my summer patch application in
july
you know you're too late so you know i
almost look at those fall applications
as
more critical than the spring
applications if you have a
you know if you know you have a
persistent summer excuse me take off
issue okay and the same rules
i'm sorry the same rules apply uh
compacted soils
ph manganese issues yeah and the
manganese you know i think the timing
you know corresponds with those fall and
spring uh applications
uh you know the you know you basically
want to kind of get that make sure that
that material is out there when the
pathogen is infecting and whatnot okay
um but yeah so
yeah a lot of the the management
recommendations are very similar across
the board okay
i didn't warn you and we're coming to
the 30 minutes but buckley's been
listening to us he act the whole time
and so he's gonna want to have something
to say carl i think he's asked something
and we got a question there
yeah richard's got a question uh do you
feel that the solid time
increased disease due to raising bulk
density at the solid time so i think you
you mentioned that a little bit john
kind of that plow layer i know we talked
about that in ag
that's that's what you're attributing
that to yeah yeah i mean and that's
i mean that's what the data supports um
we actually did show we documented it
an increase in the soil compaction the
pan layer right there at that three inch
that's why we talked about staggering
that depth and you know making sure
you're kind of breaking that up and
avoiding it i mean it's really
interesting because hollow tines
marty petrovic back in his graduate
student days used a cat scan device
to measure the compaction around the
time you can find the paper if you
if you look it up and he found even
hollow kinds
this was back in the day when paul ricci
was just starting to study cultivation i
hate i bear to say it in the 70s
uh when they were just understanding
that a plow layer could develop
i didn't know there was a significant a
difference
between the hollow tine compaction at
the bottom
uh and and the solid time uh or that the
hollow time would go at different depths
and not work the same and maybe taking
it out
uh might make all the difference i i
thought when you first started this work
there was something about
injuring that maybe the timing of the
cultivation
was an issue but you saw it over
multiple years right
we did see um we well we did see some
damage
associated with timing um so we did see
um in some years where the hollow tining
did
increase the severity of summer patch a
little bit
it didn't exist through the whole summer
but we did see that but
but we we did those those verifications
quite late okay i think the in that year
we didn't get around to verifying those
plots until like june
okay and so by june our soil
temperatures are
already pushing above 70 degrees
fahrenheit
and so the likelihood of getting any
root growth really
you know to to kind of recover from that
that aggressive cultivation
probably was quite low and again i
related back to the attrition
we ended up with less root mass but but
it is good to know
that air vacation is a damaging and
stressful
thing as much as we are in an industry
that thinks it's a solution to every
problem we have is put a hole in the
ground
and i'm not always knocking it it
usually works but i think the timing and
when you do it is uh
is pretty tricky when we're trying to
get as much rooting as as we can
and on the heels of not being able to
produce roots it makes it worse so carl
questions yeah so i got a question on
that on that
uh kind of cultivation front uh we talk
about getting the the summer patch
drenches down to the roots you know
around two inch depth
um and i kind of think well what if you
just make holes at two inches if you
just
time to a two inch depth and then go
with your drench over that
but we're also talking about this
compaction issue has that been something
they've studied just making a hole to
two inches and getting
the fungicide down that way yeah i mean
i don't know i don't know of any studies
that specifically looked at that
but i mean i to me the logic is
is worth you know it makes sense to me
um you know i think if
it seems to me that you would
potentially get some
you know get those holes you get the
material moving down there you might get
a little bit of lateral spread
um you know a little bit of downward
spread um so i mean i
you know if you can time it if you can
sync up those applications and
everything like that
then you know i think it could be
advantageous it's going to be tricky on
soils if you've got any clay in that
soil
and you do it when it's a little too wet
it's going to sheen the inside and seal
the inside of that hole and
you're nowhere you're just making little
pools of the stuff
now eventually maybe it seeps in
and so so i i've thought that
the only way to really sort of improve
this in some of these soils
is with wedding agents but the wedding
agent work the guys are doing and what
kearns is doing in north carolina just
published recently
i think he's doing that on sand and they
barely get the stuff to go
down on inch in sand john we got usga
greens they're putting on a quarter half
inch of water
it's not going barely an inch so i don't
know where i'm going in a native soil
with clay
and maybe i ought to think about
cultural practices instead of drenching
you know that intermediate cut that i
want to get rid of anyway
yep yeah no it's
there's a lot it's it's tricky i mean uh
you know i'm glad jim's doing that work
because i think it's
i think it's going to resolve a lot of
questions that we have um
but um well it raises more
right john if if if really the best
we're getting is an inch deep we're not
protecting any roots deeper than that
and if your image is any indication of
how it can be
where it's a stark line between man it
chopped all these and there's
they're pretty good here if it's a hard
line like that
and that organism is plentiful in the
soil
um it seems to me that you
need your soils and the chemical
properties
and maybe grass types do we have
varieties
that are different here john are there
varieties there's
some varieties um in kentucky bluegrass
that show some
some better um more more resistant i
think barbetta
uh kentucky bluegrass tends to be a
little bit more tolerant
i wouldn't say that any of them are i'm
sorry
not annual bluegrass no no no no okay
carl questions uh yeah no questions so
um
i think uh we can wrap it at that right
around half an hour
um really appreciate you coming on john
it's great conversation
yeah that's fun thanks guys appreciate
that carl survey
yeah uh i'll throw this survey one more
time uh
in the uh chat box here for those five
of you that watch the video
fill out the survey right right so um
you know we've gotten a lot of responses
so far but i'll throw that again in
there
um and you know thanks for sticking with
us we'll see if we continue to do this
but uh yeah we'll see you next
week for sure we'll make a plan soon
john best of michelle and the kids take
care
all right take care everybody thank you
see ya
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu